[Music]
well congratulations it seems like you
guys had such a magical experience were
you hiding the plan from her for long it
was it a secret what happened yeah no I
yeah he was what's up III took someone
to chin you know throughout yeah kind of
leading up to it because apparently I'd
never plan anything really rude
I was super rude and I'm not gonna say
went through his things but I went
through his things and didn't see
anything so I was even more road ahead
of the trip because you're thinking is
it gonna happen yeah and then I prepared
myself and like it's not happening you
hid the ring somewhere else where were
you putting it yeah no I I mean honestly
I it was in my bookbag like the only
time where I felt like oh man the plan
could get busted his uh had security
check both our bags got pulled to the
side and both oh you know her back was
they went through her bag and then they
got to my bag and I'm like you can't
travel with this water I'm like ah the
liquids it's too much some other eyes
well so you were planning it for how
long before it happened
no I actually you know asked her father
obviously that was a huge thing and with
our tour we were in Utah I think
probably beginning of May so it was a
I propose so got about a little more
than that and were you surprised then
since you didn't find anything in the
back I was shocked because I'm very
traditional and so he knew that talking
to my dad was really important and he
was very adamant about doing it in
person and so the first thing I actually
said to him when he proposed to me was
did you ask my dad and he was like yes
got it yes I'm like so I was shocked she
said that before yes yes you went and
talked to dad in person yeah yeah it's
really awkward but it was cool
like a secret trip so it was after their
tour after they saw the tour in Utah and
I mean after the show you're usually
just like in a towel and of course his
shirts always often you know I used that
every every trick in the book every
super dad was that an emotional chat
though yeah yeah was actually oh yeah
this was the first time for me and I
just such such beauty and that you know
in any any individuals coming together
and doing it in a no traditional way
that matters you know so I mean I mean
there's everyone does a different and
beauty
regardless but the fact that I was able
to speak to her dad and ask for his
permission and he yeah I was like and he
gave it so it was a beautiful thing and
I knew how much it meant to her too so I
think it was emotional for my dad so I'm
the I'm the baby of the girls and so I'm
his last baby girl to get married how
does it feel to now be walking around
calling each other fiance it's very fun
it feels very fancy I love it it's cool
the fact that people are so much more
interested in me now than ever
hopeless romances how did you know he
was the one how did you know she was the
one the first time I saw him actually my
first day of Dancing with the Stars for
her soul right after I finished so I
think you dance I was the only new
person joining the cast I'll never
forget it I walked into my cabin and I
was so nervous and he was one of the
first people I saw and he came up and
tried to introduce himself and I was
like oh gosh he's going whoop and that
was like five years ago I mean it's been
a long journey since spent but now I
yeah I am love at first sight for you
basically yeah
he's not just a feeling that floods over
you what is yeah it took a while but I
knew he was special and yeah he's proven
though yeah I think love at first sight
is a beautiful thing I was very
attracted to her and by her demeanor but
I think it's about timing I think
everything in life is about timing and
so you were saying you admired him yeah
I'm very lucky you know that's the truth
and I I think time comes when you just
have to acknowledge how lucky you are to
have some people in your life and
I realized that and that that's what I
mean by timing I just realized like wow
this incredible woman loves me like more
do you really need and so that's when I
found like I got it I got a lock it down
she makes me better you know and I
recognized that and I was like why would
I
how does she make you better which makes
me a little bit more accountable a
little bit gives me a tough time it
always challenges me he makes you better
- absolutely well let's talk about it
Maxim PETA just had this whole big
wedding did you learn from their wedding
planning experience at all and what do
you guys want to do yeah look I just
want to put it out there right now for
my friends you're not invited like
you're not invited and don't take it
personally you know it's me talking
budgets we talking 2018
we're talking like I celebrate you every
day right why we need to pay extra for
another meal I see the eye rolls Jenna
no I think we're gonna do our own
version of our dream wedding so are you
guys low-key are you elope what are we
talking to me at this point I would love
to the low because wedding planning is
stressful and so is I think we want to
enjoy being engaged for a little bit so
I'm definitely on Pinterest swiping and
saving things but for right now I think
we just wanna enjoy Vegas
so a destination wedding except like so
I'm not sure about destination wedding
sound anything that's like a must for
you like three must for your wedding
that you want to make happen all I know
is that I want my family there and I
want him there and that's it I think I
haven't ever haven't like looked at
dresses enough I need to try them on I
think but it's all very exciting and new
so I'm excited
did you cry when he got down a loco yes
I was like shocked and then I was
emotional and I didn't ugly cry and oh
there's a there's a video I like I hired
a bunch of this was in Venice I hired a
bunch of like undercover cameras so it's
coming it's coming it's gonna be a video
soon but uh yeah it was beautiful it was
special and like I said thank God you
know she said yes
[Music]